Magnus Carlson's hand-picked successor
alireza faruja ejected Hikaru Nakamura
from the chess kid Cup in day two
farugia showed maturity Beyond his years
creating inexorable positional pressure
in both games in game one he established
a significant Advantage but the always
elusive Hikaru escaped with a half point
and there we go it is a draw after all
that drama missed opportunity though for
alireza farisha in the second game
alireza grabbed the two Bishops and
demonstrated a textbook example of the
power of the potent pair
a fine endgame win Advanced alireza who
admitted finding humor in washing
watching karu's famous expressions
Hikaru who won the previous Champions
chess tournament is eliminated after two
straight match losses in the chess kid
Cup oh man that's it